a flare-up in fighting around europe's
largest nuclear power plant is fueling
fears of possible nuclear disaster
russia and ukraine blame each other for
the shelling near zaparica how much of a
risk does the conflict pose and can a
catastrophe be avoided this is inside
story
[Music]
[Music]
hello there and welcome to the program
i'm laura kyle
concerns of a disaster at europe's
largest nuclear facility are growing
shelling has intensified around the
russian-controlled zaparica power plant
in ukraine moscow and kiev blame each
other for the attacks russia controls
the facility but ukraine is operating it
vladimir putin has agreed to grant
access to inspectors from the un atomic
watchdog the kremlin made the
announcement after a phone call between
president putin and french president
emmanuel macron in a statement it said
both leaders noted the importance of
sending an iaea mission to the plant as
soon as possible to allow experts to
assess the situation on the ground the
russian side confirmed its readiness to
provide the necessary assistance to the
agency's inspectors
well ukraine's president vladimir
zelensky has welcomed the inspection but
says specific details still need to be
worked out
the return of comprehensive security to
the zaporichia nuclear power plant and
inner hoda may start with this mission
i'm grateful to all who joined the
effort if the russian radiation
blackmail will go on the summer may
enter the history of europe as one of
the most tragic of all time because in
no rule book in any station in the world
there's a procedure in case some
terrorist state turns a nuclear power
plant into a target meanwhile u.n
secretary general antenna guterres has
again called for the demilitarization of
the plant
i remain greatly concerned about the
enthalpic situation in and around
europe's largest nuclear power plant in
zappos
common sense must prevail to avoid any
actions that might be endangered
physical integrity safety or security
and delivery plan
and the facility must not be used as
part of any military operation
instead agreement is urgently needed to
establish zapoligine as purely civilian
infrastructure and to ensure the safety
of the area
we'll bring in our panel in just a
moment first let's take a closer look at
the zaparica nuclear plant it was one of
the first sites seized when russia
invaded ukraine in february the plant
may be under russian control but
ukrainian engineers still operate it
atomic energy researchers have warned of
a meltdown or radiation leak if power
supplies are damaged by shelling and the
u.n watchdog has warned fighting around
the facility poses a very real risk of
nuclear disaster
let's bring in our guests now and from
moscow andre federal former deputy
foreign minister of russia from odessa
hannah celeste security studies program
director at the ukrainian prison think
tank and from vienna robert kelly a
former director of the international
atomic energy agency thank you all very
much for being here with us today
andre let's start with you because we
heard there the ukrainian president
accusing russia of radiation blackmail
let me give you a chance to respond to
that
okay this is the question that uh the
future of this nuclear power station
is very important for the whole
situation in europe and uh not only for
russia and
ukraine
the question is who will be responsible
if something will happen because the
risk that there might be a
nuclear pollution is still very high
and both sides are really accusing each
other
uh in this situation
and ukraine is very firmly blaming you
what is what are you saying what is
moscow saying about this
uh moscow is saying that
it's it's not possible because there are
no heavy arms and uh the the shelling is
coming from the other side of the
area from nikopol which is on the
ukrainian control and this is the task
of
moscow to bring
inspection and to show and to try to
confirm the whole world
that it's ukraine which is responsible
for this dangerous situation okay hannah
your response to that is ukraine
shelling the area is it the one
responsible for the dangerous situation
you know the problem is that russian
accusations are happening without any
proofs and let's remember that uh first
and foremost the russian forces must not
be at the territory of the nuclear plant
and already for one month we have the
personal more than 500 people and more
than 50
equipment at the territory of the
nuclear plant including those that are
inside of the building inside of the
engine rooms number one and two we have
quite a number of satellite images
proving these we have the latest video
that appeared today go from inside
showing these cars that is the total
violation of the all safety regulations
about the nuclear facilities so that
should be number one what these forces
are doing inside of the nuclear plant
making it de facto a big explosive
facility the second is we had back in
june
only now international journalists
started to pay attention to the problem
but ukrainian state attracted attention
of the international organizations back
in june because there were quite a
number of videos or from the security
cameras proved when russians tried to
occupy this nuclear facility how first
they were shelling it as for now we also
have quite a number of videos and by the
professionals can really identify for
which side first of all this challenge
is happening and the second is uh it's
very easy to do according to the time
difference between the first explosion
and the second meaning it is like from
the start of the uh ammunition and the
targeting and all the military experts
as for now are saying that it would be
impossible to shell from uh nicopo and
to have this short period of time that
definitely it is happening just as well
okay hannah i just want to ask that if
this site is so sensitive which it
clearly is it's europe's biggest nuclear
power plant why was it not better
protected in the first place against a
russian takeover
one of the reason exactly was because
ukrainian armed forces tried not to
fight around it understanding the risks
so we assumed that the nuclear power
plant will be the non-touched uh
territory uh that's why uh first of all
at that time you need to remember that
we had fightings all around
approximately 2000 kilometers of the
front so we couldn't just put the uh
personal around for security and we
couldn't bring the heavy weapons there
otherwise we would have the fighting
that would jeopardize the safety of
these facilities
and at that time we had the fightings
around mario pal and in many other
places very important so i hear it was
unfortunately um balance or necessity uh
between the nuclear safety or the
possibility to defend these facilities
uh andre i mean it does seem very clear
doesn't it that the threat does come
from the simple fact that russian forces
are somewhere where they shouldn't be
where they don't belong
so the russian forces occupied the
territory of the nuclear power station
already on february 28th
take into consideration the importance
of this uh
power plant also for the territories
which is now under russian control
and uh
one of the elements of this battle
around this uh zaporizia uh nuclear
power plant is that if it will be cut
off uh the whole nearly the whole
territory which is now under russian
control
many things simply impossible there it's
not the power plant itself it's quite
well protected i mean reactors
the problem is
nuclear waste storage
which is not protected enough and which
include includes
many uh radioactive materials including
including plutonium 240 which is very
dangerous
okay
bob let's bring you in at this stage
because we've got both sides blaming
each other for the threat at this
nuclear power plant what is the actual
threat that exists there the actual
threat is is much much less than all
these politicians and diplomats are
putting out there this is a huge plant
with a very great safety record it's
been run for decades it's probably as
safe today as it ever was although
they're losing some of the redundant
backup systems that are keeping it as
safe as it would be but as people are
arguing about you know these details of
waste storage and things like that
they're missing the big picture totally
if you compare this plant let's say and
i liked your lead in mentioned meltdown
fukushima there were about three
thousand people died and that counts the
people who were injured in traffic
accidents chasing their dogs leaving the
site and all
twenty thousand died in the tsunami
um
if you look at three thousand people
potentially dying at a meltdown at
fukushima
at japa asia that's unfortunate but the
idea that's going to contaminate all of
western europe makes you laugh i mean
this is such a stupid claim the people
making these claims are either ignorant
or totally political or both and i
suspect it's both
hannah what do you make of that that the
the the threat the claim of the threat
is over exaggerated in this situation
no the question is that we are
definitely talking about uh several
possibilities of what is happening there
uh nuclear waste about which just uh we
talked about it is 170 containers it is
one we also have the problem of the
radiated waters over there and also
because it is near the river it can have
much bigger effect but don't forget
about the explosions that we have inside
of the engines uh definitely just
shelling from outside will not make the
second chernobyl because the parisian
power plant being built with the better
security uh compared to um
what we had in chernobyl however if you
blow up from inside and that is the
possibility because we heard
unfortunately such threats plus we have
a lot of minds around the territory at
the perimeter so it can be the accident
even we need to understand that it
shouldn't be the intentional act of
terrorism it can be just an accident
because of the uh irregulation or
because of the neglecting of the safety
measures and we saw it in chernobyl in
february and march and we see it right
now what is happening at the territory
any type of accident unfortunately we
cannot predict and if possible one very
small uh correction to what being said
by my uh russian colleague about the
energy provision and importance of the
parisia uh the situation is that the
russian representatives of the energy
company for the last few weeks been
trying to disconnect the parisian power
plant from producing and delivering the
energy to the uh um uncontrolled
territories of person for example region
with only a goal to reconnect it to the
crimea greed to just stealing the energy
produced by the ukrainian power plant so
we need to understand that russians are
using current situation in the upper
asia both for the nuclear terrorism and
black mailing but also for the
satisfaction of the necessity of what
they need for crimea andrei
do you agree with that claim by hannah
that russia is planning to shut down the
plant to reconnect it and redivert or
divert all the electricity all the power
to crimea and to russian control
territory thereby shutting off vast
waves of ukraine from the energy
as i mentioned before uh without
this power plant uh russian-controlled
territories will be without electricity
and for russian uh government and for
president putin it's a very key issue
the vital issue that's why there is so
many noise around this nuclear power
plant
and
at the same time of course i cannot
exclude that if russia will continue to
control uh zappos nuclear power plant uh
it can be cut off from ukrainian
electricity but if i can just jump in
because the u.s secretary general just
in the last few days said that this
energy created by this power plant is
ukrainian energy
yes it's ukrainian energy but of course
uh in this very situation it's used by
russia
and part of it goes to ukraine part of
it goes to russian controlled
territories
but as i said it's much more at this
stage a political issue than just a
technical issue
because
what russia is
afraid of frankly speaking is to lose
control over this nuclear power plant
it's very important for the survival of
the territories where uh russia is now
under where under control which are
under control
uh robert kelly how if we do go back to
the technicalities of it how easy is it
possible for russia to shut down a
nuclear power plant and divert the
electricity it produces the energy it
produces to a different area how
difficult is that to do the first part
of your question is it's trivial to shut
down nuclear power plant i think that
four of the units are down right now and
since russia built these plants many of
them in other places as well as here
they know exactly how to do it and sell
the ukrainians there's decades of
experience as far as disconnecting it
from the grid i've
talked about this for the last week uh
there's been a lot going on outside the
planet including hundreds of kilometers
away of blowing up substations and power
lines in that sense ukraine is winning
the battle because what they're doing is
they're isolating the plant the plant
can't send electricity to anybody right
now it has to be shot down and it's
become a 40 billion dollar white
elephant that both sides want both want
it after the war and they want it to be
safe
hannah we've just had uh president putin
agree access to the iaea to assess the
plant to monitor the plant of course
there are going to be challenges to that
visit taking place key most at the
moment is how those nuclear inspectors
actually get to the plant whether they
go via russian controlled areas or via
kiev why is ukraine and see them going
through russian controlled areas no
first of all because it will be the
violation of the international law and
breaking of the border regimes uh that's
why and it is quite safe to go for them
through the ukrainian territory the u.n
secretary general just uh yesterday was
uh in ukraine and uh from the ukrainian
control territory to the nuclear power
plant is just five kilometers so if the
russian forces around the nuclear power
plant will stop uh fighting for several
minutes you can pass five kilometers it
is not 100 kilometers or something like
this uh two months ago the uh u.n
undersecretary uh traveled with the
proper arrangements to marijuana when we
discussed the uh
surrender of the azov
defenders it was possible to do and the
situation around the parisia is less
dangerous than it used to be in
marijuana so as for now all we need is
the good will to stop fighting and as we
know now we have this decision that the
delegation should travel through the
ukrainian uh territory for me it was
more surprised by the russian president
demanded it traveling through russia uh
so andre why is the russian president
demanding that they travel through
russian controlled areas why don't they
want them to go through keeve it's very
simple because if the
delegation if the inspectors will go via
ukrainian territory from kiev
which is
logical in certain way so in this case
uh
it is considered as moscow in moscow as
a recognition of ukrainian control over
this territory which is unacceptable for
putin but why is that unacceptable
oh because uh
moscow is considering the parisia as a
part of controlled territories and let's
not forget that for september there is a
plan to
organize referendum in the parisian area
uh to uh join russia to
to be integrated into russia
that's why this is political background
okay let's assume for a moment robert
that the mona the the iaea monitors do
get to the plant
you were on a monitoring mission in iraq
i know this is a very different scenario
but in this particular case is apparatus
what might these inspectors be looking
for
you need to break it down into two
things the inspectors who go are people
whose job is to do inventories and
audits of nuclear material uh so they
are entirely focused on those things
they have no experience and they have no
training in safety security uh that kind
of effort
then the iaea from time to time and in
very few cases has had special missions
like the south africa
uh to iraq to libya those are special
cases where they bring in outsiders a
lot of americans usually and those
people come in and they are very
familiar with the technology which iaea
is not and they carry out a mission but
it's not an inspection so it'll very
much depend on who iaa reaches out to
and brings in has experts people who
know about power lines for example and
transformers which is probably
completely outside iaea's
bodies
the
aviation
chief um raphael grossi said himself
that he might be willing to go if
necessary would that lend a certain
credibility to this mission which is
surely as we've seen just from today's
discretion discussion going to become
extremely political
absolutely raphael has a amazing history
as a lawyer in the nuclear business he
knows nuclear law inside and out he was
head of nuclear suppliers group uh he
would be a very good person to lead it
as a
professional lawyer and and
international uh law expert i don't
think he would lead any of the technical
people that's not something he would
want to do okay
andre this
of course i think hannah did a beautiful
job of explaining that none of the
accidents that she mentioned that might
happen over the next few months are any
more than just a reasonable small
problem
the the idea of contaminating europe is
nonsense okay
andre the
agency visit the u.n agency visit is
essentially going to be entering a war
zone unless this area
becomes demilitarized this is something
russia has rejected is it going to
reconsider that
it's totally rejected by moscow uh
because the argument is very simple if
russian troops will we will withdraw
from the nuclear power plant
so ukrainians can create some kind of
provocation and then accuse russia et
cetera et cetera that's why i'm
absolutely sure that there will be no
step back from putin he will insist uh
to keep
a power plant
under russian military control and
concerning the mission uh the
international atomic agency
mission uh one of the tasks of moscow i
can say very clearly is to show
to this mission parts of missiles and
trying to convince this mission that
it's
ukrainian missiles or even uh
american high mars
system missiles so this is one of the
political tasks for moscow okay robert i
can see you shaking your head there do
you want to respond well i don't think
anybody at the iaea knows the difference
between high mars and other kinds of
missiles that's not what they do they
all have to bring in outside experts to
do that
from outside the iaea so it's not an
iaea inspection it would be an
international mission okay hannah do you
support does ukraine support the idea of
demilitarizing this area i mean it has
been active in this area will it
withdraw troops if necessary
yes ukraine talked about the possible
demolition for several weeks and we were
ready uh for these acts understanding
the danger that is happening there and
honestly for us it is quite an illogic
in the phrase that in case this
territory is demilitarized uh ukrainians
will arrange a provocation there is no
sense for us in provocation because we
need the energy and we need this power
plant working as it supplies the energy
for one third uh territory of the
country and we are coming to autumn and
winter so quite difficult uh
seasons for uh in terms of energy when
we will need all the capacities of this
nuclear plant so that's why for us the
uh demilitarization also will mean that
such towns as nikopa will not be under
the serious attack because the last two
weeks uh this town that is just across
the river from uh in ergod where the
parisia uh power plant station is under
significant fire and it is happening
definitely from the russian side and uh
the last two weeks they are just
demolishing this tower demilitarization
also will need a certain rest from these
attacks for such times okay robert again
i can see you uh shaking your head there
you go to respond
i think it's very important to the
nuclear power plant be guarded by
somebody uh the only people that the
russians can use right now to guard it
is their military and so it would make
uh it would be a very poor idea for the
russians to pull the military out and
leave the plant totally unguarded on the
other hand if they give it over to the
ukrainians then they just lost their
prize of war and that's a big prize 40
billion dollars
indeed okay it has been an extremely
interesting discussion we will leave it
there for today i have have no doubt
that when the iaea does enter zaparica
we'll be revisiting this topic many
times over thank you very much indeed
all of you for taking the time to join
us today andre fedorov hannah celeste
and robert kelly
and thank you too very much for watching
you can see the program again anytime by
visiting our website that's altazera.com
and for further discussion do go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
aj inside story you can also join the
conversation on twitter our handlers at
aj inside story from me laura kyle and
the whole team here it's bye for now
[Music]
you